kovid may not have been in the headlines
for a while but it hasn't gone away far
from it as new data shows according to
the latest results from the office for
national statistics infection survey
more than three and a quarter million
people in the uk had coveted in the week
ending march the 12th that's about one
in every 21 people and after a steady
falling cases in the first two months of
the year the prevalence has been
increasing through march and the old
number is rising too so what's going on
well for a start our behavior has
relaxed the lifting of plan b at the end
of january led to a decline in face
masks lateral flow tests social
distancing and self-isolation and those
trends accelerated at the end of
february when the prime minister
outlined his plan to live with kovid and
that all gives the virus more
opportunities to spread but the virus
has changed too at the start of the year
the original omicron variant called ba
0.1 accounted for almost all covered
cases but in mid-february its closely
related spin-off called ba 0.2 here in
light blue began to take off and take
over now accounting for more than 75
percent of cases the two viruses are so
similar some scientists call them sister
variants but ba 0.2 is 1.4 times more
infectious and that's a rocket booster
that's driving up cases here in the uk
as well as hospital admissions but while
in earlier waves there was a lag between
people getting infected and then needing
emergency care this time the rise in
cases and hospitalizations happened at
the same time it suggests many patients
are going into hospital with the virus
not because of the virus it's still
disruptive for the nhs but public health
experts say the rise should be
short-lived
i do think that over the next
two to four weeks we will see a leveling
off as has been seen in other countries
so other countries have been ahead of us
nba too and we've seen a rapid downturn
in in infections in those countries
as as the population immunity has gained
covet is expected to become endemic
it'll come and go probably for decades
but for now immunity is good enough for
us to lead more normal lives